when we think of the American Civil War
we often think of several things of its
leaders like Abraham Lincoln and
Jefferson Davis of Confederate and Union
troops shooting it out in bloody combat
or of what the Civil War was all about
what isn't often considered is the role
that Native Americans played in the
conflict and how the Civil War affected
them so what did Native Americans
actually do who did they side with and
what did they think of the American
Civil War it shouldn't surprise you that
Native Americans weren't exactly keen on
the white Americans who had
progressively been taking more and more
land from them over the previous
centuries the primary tribes that were
affected by this were collectively known
as the Five Civilized tribes who had
previously been forced westward in the
decades prior to the outbreak of the
Civil War these five tribes were the
Cherokee the creeks the Seminole with
the Chickasaw and the Choctaw and all of
them sided with the Confederacy largely
because they have the Washington
government it's responsible for their
forced deportations and also because
many of them had economies dependent on
slaves not in their entirety of course
many within these tribes had sympathies
towards the Union with respect to
abolitionism not only that but one major
concern was the repercussions for
choosing the wrong side they'd already
lost a lot they didn't wish to lose more
these divisions ripped many tribes apart
and led to people from the same family
fighting for both sides one man of
particular importance was a Creek chief
for pottery Yolo who argued that Native
Americans should get involved with the
Civil War because it was the white man's
problem in response to this the
Confederate aligned tribes attacked in
late 1861 and apatheia Hollow fled north
into Kansas where he would remain until
his death in 1863 in early 1862 the
Union launched an offensive into Indian
lands and despite the best efforts of
the Confederate aligned Native Americans
there under the command of Stand Watty
the Confederacy was beaten back soon
after this the Union captured the chief
of the Cherokee and by the end of the
next year it was in control of all of
Native American territory did this mean
that the war was over for Native
Americans no in fact many were sent
eastward to go and fight there whilst
those that remained waged a guerrilla
war the primary leader of the Native
American Raiders was against and Watty
and he spent over a year raiding Union
supply trains what he was so good at his
job that when the Confederates
restructured the army he was placed in
command of all of his Native American
units and promoted to the rank of
Brigadier General and despite the best
efforts of what he in the Native
Americans in the West the Union still
won the war and two months after General
Lee surrendered the Native American
tribes capitulated as well so after the
war what
happened to the Native American tribes
had sided with the Confederacy well
nothing good
whose slaves owned by natives were to be
freed and given full citizenship within
the tribes and what's morally it was a
good thing economically it was
absolutely devastating for these tribes
the tribes were also forced to sell much
of their lands to the federal government
at a reduced rate the money raised from
which was then promptly appropriated as
war reparations of course there were
more than five tribes involved in the
civil war but none of them came out of
it well even those who weren't to
involve like the Comanches or the
Cheyenne's were forced to sign similar
documents which confiscated their lands
and moved them to reservations the
federal government soon headed by
veterans of the Civil War who for the
most part had a distaste for their
former Native American enemies ignored
these treaties where it suited them
tribes would lose yet more land to be
placed on reservations and would spend
over a decade trying to fix the
divisions which had played them during
the Civil War I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
the special thanks to my patreon
supporters who you can see on screen
here and with an extra special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologist
party-boy Co Danny Maloney Colin
Castleman Rob Waterhouse are in the
white Michael Reynolds H way an emperor
chris wicker Gustav Swann Gareth Turner
spinning three plates David Silverman
Winston Cawood Maggie packs Kowski
Christian check' Anthony Beckett
Robert Wetzel Skye Chappell and Ike